each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
so let's get started it is a pleasure to
introduce palvin or shot a repeat
visitor who's going to talk to us about
password aging policies and quantifying
security advantages Paul is um well
known to many of us he used to work on
Krypto for a long long time but then saw
the error of his ways and decided to
start working on passwords all right
thank you Cormac so very apropos intro
because what I'm going to do in this
talk is actually go back to crypto and
use crypto to set so we're gonna wee-wee
Ralph we're all familiar with password
aging policies and I don't need to ask
people how excited they are about
changing their passwords every every 30
or 70 or 90 days generally it's not very
it's not the thing people get up in the
morning and say today is the day I get
to change my password I'm very excited
um but the the problem here that I'm
looking at is is the expectation is that
somehow this helps in this improve
security and we get this fuzzy feeling
or we're somehow convinced that this is
going to help security lot but the
question asked is how much does it help
and in which ways and so that's the
question I want to explore this some
this work actually if you're interested
in looking at the details it's in a
paper that will appear shortly in a
special issue of designs codes and
cryptography Scott vanstone actually was
my uh my PhD advisor and so the the
thing about password agent policies is
we have this general notion or we come
to believe that it helps security in
some vague ways and I'll talk about a
couple of them later but you know
quantitatively what is what is the
benefit what gain what benefit do you
and in order to answer that question the
easiest thing to do is to try and
formalize things now if you formalize
things you end up making assumptions and
models that don't actually map on to the
real world and so then you know what's
the value of your model well I do start
here by formalizing and going to a
crypto security model where we're rather
than passwords which are chosen
in a very skewed distribution by users
we're going to start out looking at
cryptographic keys which are which are
randomly chosen and equally probable in
order to figure out what the bounds are
and then I want to take that because we
can get precise answers and try and get
some insight into mapping that on to
real user passwords it'll turned out
that'll that'll give us some lower
bounds and with skewed distributions we
can then see what those bounds can tell
us and it turns out that it gives us
some insights as to how bad things are
in it even in even in the idealized
setting things aren't great in terms of
the advantages that we I'm happy to take
questions throughout I don't think i
have a I don't have an awful lot of
slides here so it's probably best to
keep the context of a particular slide
so so jump out if you have some sub
questions okay so here's the background
a thing to think about during the time
um suppose you change your password
continuously basically as often as
interface allows does that prevent
successful guessing attacks so just try
and think about that in the background
and then we'll try and put some precise
numbers to that question so here's the
model we're going to start out with I'm
not claiming that this maps well onto
user passwords but this is where we
start by for mice so we have a crypto
key search problem you get a randomly
chosen key or assuming we're going to do
an exhaustive search so there's a fixed
key space assume there's capital R keys
we assume that an attacker actually are
going to get a guess going to be able to
guess through all keys all our keys and
we're going to have two different
periods we're going to talk about one is
the exhaustive guessing time is
exhausted period of time that's capital
T and the second time period we're going
to talk about is the the password
expiration policy period which is
capital T and we're going to go through
a set of different sequences here we're
going to look at what the relationship
between the exhaustive guessing period
and the expiration period is
and then consider the different cases as
well so we're going to assume for
simplicity and online guessing attack
i'll have some comments against about
offline later on it's a deterministic
finite search so the attacker will be
successful if you do not change your key
by the time he's guessed every single
key through the key space somewhere in
there will be your key and he'll have
guessed it okay the policy period is
known so for example you have to change
your key every 30 days or 90 days river
so that period is known but the attacker
does not know at which precise moment
within that period an attacker changes
is key I saw a user changes is key and
what's the attack gets to the end of his
key space we assume that he will just
start guessing again now when he guesses
through the key space a second time he
might guess through it in a different
deterministic order but it is a
deterministic order gain that he's going
to go through it and so he'll guess
through the keys sequence once every
single one once and then you know
possibly different order next time and
we'll assume these are random orderings
and that allows us to get the
probabilities and analyze precisely as
well as just that you're you're positing
that this policy is primarily against
yessum okay so it turns out that that's
a good question um so the analysis is
simplest if we guess about if we assume
it's an online guessing attack it turns
out there's a little hitch in this
particular model that if there's a if
it's an offline guessing attack um how
does that map on the real world will it
turns out if it's offline if you
actually change your key then the
attacker actually can't be verifying
offline unless he grabs another copy of
the key file and so then you have to
make so just to avoid that issue right
now let's assume it's online guessing we
don't have to worry about that little
little glitch
consider which is how long between an
attacker breaking your key and him
selling to the black market is a bad guy
in Ukraine will see on your money that's
another question to you exactly any
sense of a lockout sort of thing at a
time period of defense for the online i
SPECT no exponential in this case we're
just going to assume these are defensive
measures which can help you stop a text
but let's let's just say that they don't
do that it turns out surprisingly
there's a lot of online properties that
don't do that and actually they don't
don't even do throttling but anyway so
I'm just trying so I want to get through
this simple model first get some precise
answers and equations and then map to
how how that maps on to passwords okay
so here's so chapter is only focused on
one account well again for this analysis
let's assume that these are guesses on
one account and then we can go through
and see if he's going to you know in a
real world the gas the attacker is going
to probably guess the most probable
probable password against all the counts
and then the second most probable
against elegant but some attackers are
looking to attack your account but if
it's a generic attack they would
probably you do probable guesses most
probable guesses against all the
accounts for which they have access okay
so here's the keys k with case of one k
sub 2 up to case of capital R let's
assume that's a you know visual
representation of the key space and the
users key is going to be just lower case
k without without a subscript and is
going to dress the attacker is going to
guess key case uh by that time to use of
I and right bingos that that value there
would be where where he guesses the
correct key okay so the question then is
if you change your user key K 2 K star
um so after you lowercase new units of
time if you change your key what
security advantage results so what is
the change in the probability of
successful guess overall our guesses key
points we're assuming its overall our
guesses okay so that's the model we
understand
going to answer this question precisely
and then we want to nap it to a real
problem of interest okay so for the
first analysis let's assume that the the
expiration sorry the exhaustive guessing
period the time it takes to the attacker
to guess all our keys is capital T and
that's going to be less than or equal to
the policy change period which is which
is capital P which is your 90 days or
river okay now for the attacker to be
successful if we assume that there's
there's two periods call it w1 and w2
think about the the users key being k
and then k star am and the attacker is
successful if he guesses k while it's
active in pier w 1 or k star in w2 and
the only time that he's unsuccessful is
if it's not k if it's neither k within
w1 nor k star mw2 we can we can go
through and figure out the exact
probabilities here because if the
proportion of keys and w1 if it's
changed after u units of time the
proportion of keys is u divided by
capital R let's call that Q and that
leaves the proportion 1 minus Q and W to
and simply from the sizes of those
partitions you get the probabilities
because we're assuming it's a randomly
chosen key and they're all equally
probable okay so just from that analysis
and what's on that slide the only case
of success of attacker failure is if K
is not in w1k stars not in w2 down at
the bottom here and the probability is
simply going to be 1 minus Q times Q so
the probability of success is going to
be adding up q1 and q2 and q3
probability of tack or failure is Q form
okay so it turns out that our probably
success is 1 minus Q plus Q squared
probably a failure is 1 minus that you
might excuse great does anyone know how
to figure out a min max you
2 minus Q squared so that equals 0 min
max Kruse q because one half probability
of failure one quarter probably success
is three quarters okay so this is what
it looks like you're going to get the
minimum here probably the success gets
minimized if the user changes exactly
halfway through the period it's still
probably success is still greater than
equal to 75 percent if you didn't change
it at all one hundred percent
probability of success for the attacker
if you do change it at the optimal time
it drops to seventy-five percent okay so
this is the x-axis is the proportion of
the key space searched before the user
changes the key why is probability of
attacker success okay okay so that's a
simple base case and then we're going to
go through some more realistic cases all
right okay so if the search fails again
what's the attack are going to do
they're going to repeat the search
starting through starting through the
key space in a possibly different
deterministic order now if you then go
through I different searches lower case
I then the probability of success is
going to be 1 minus the probability that
he fails on all the searches so it's
going to be 1 minus 1 cor to the I ok so
this is what happens across the bottom
now we have the number of searches that
the attacker gets and you know already
by the by the point 75 probabilistic
says here goes up 2.9 375 then its
ninety-eight percent 99.6 purpose so
even with a small number of total
periods t the attacker is going to have
near guaranteed success okay so that's
not surprising because what you're doing
here is you're giving the attacker many
more guesses what turns out to be
important is how many guesses does the
attack your get and changing the key
ends up not not changing the overall
probability of success up here
so our summary from this is that when
the exhaustive period t is less than or
equal to policy expiration period
capital P the policy doesn't really help
us he doesn't give us a lot of hope
humming or you know certainly in any
sort of environment you would hope that
the attacker is going to have less than
a ninety-eight percent or ninety nine
percent chance of success right okay all
right so that was our base analysis
where tea was less than go to pee it
gives us you know exactly the new wishin
for if T was equal to twice the policy
period p well the optimal thing here for
the for the defender to do is to change
their key halfway through the pier in
fact that was kind of what we modeled
when we modeled if you if you don't have
to change your key until 90 days most
users will not change it until 90 days
and so there they'll they'll you'll
almost always have it pushed out to the
end but the optimal thing to do here if
T was equal to to be the optimal thing
would still be to change it after 45
days we can't expect the users to do
that but that's what they would be best
of doing if we knew exactly what the
exact tackers search time was we don't
know that so it's very hard so all the
analysis we do here and it's actually
assuming that the defender changes the
key at the optimal time we couldn't even
achieve that with with real users
because we don't know what the real
attackers yeah okay okay so let's go
forward a little bit more now suppose we
generalize suppose rather than then T
equal to p or t equal to p we say T
equals lowercase T times feet so for
example now the policy change period
sorry their policy expiration period
capital P maybe is 30 days one month and
the search time might be 24 months so
little lowercase T would be 24 here so
this may be this models more of the
space right so what happens here well
the analysis is almost exactly the same
the easiest way to go through the
analysis is to assume the case lower
case T equals 3 so now we've got three
periods here w 1 2 & 3 rather than just
be one and to go through it in your head
for three but every time you want to use
three stick in a tea instead you get
exactly the same analysis the only time
the attack will fail is if the key for
each period fails to be in all three of
those so it's going to be the
probability of failure is going to be 1
minus 1 over T to the T probably success
1 minus 1 minus 1 over T to the T and
magically this little e comes out here I
don't know how that happens in
mathematics some some somebody jig the
system many many years ago and this
number comes up so it turns out that if
if T gets very very large in this case
so the exhausted search period for the
attacker is very very large the probably
success is still going to be sixty-three
percent or so okay so what this is what
graphically we have we start out here
this along the x-axis is is T and T is
basically tells us that the relationship
between capital T and capital T here so
that's how many full exhaustive searches
the attacker gets within one policy
sorry that's that's how many policy
periods there are in an exhaustive
search period and we come down here and
very rapidly we hit a lower limit so
that the attacker search as you can
think of this as the attacker search
power getting weaker the expectation of
success of the tax success falls but it
doesn't get any lower than 0 point 632
okay so there's a I know intuitively you
might have thought it would fall further
than that the numbers just tell us it
doesn't fall any further okay so so that
was for the case capital T is equal to
lowercase T times B now next thing we
want to consider is again suppose we
have multiple search multiple full
oster searches I I periods full
exhaustive search then the probability
success is going to be well one minus
the probability of failure in each of
those we just get the exponent I on the
right hand side here again now if we
graph this one I think this tells really
the full story we want to get so the
difference here we on the on the what x
axis I've got how many full exhaustive
search periods we have and now the
y-axis here is still the probability of
attacker success although this axis is
kind of what you saw before and the
other grass here's our here's our
probability of success was 1.0 if you
don't with just one search period it's
1.0 if you don't change your key at all
its point 75 if you if you change it
once so that's T equals 2 it's going to
drop down our lower it hits the limit
here of 0 point 632 so this is all for
one search period but then you go across
here and in this graph we're showing T
as increasing with these different
curves so T equals 1 is this curve T
equals 2 is this curve and it comes down
T equals 128 is this curve it's not much
different than T equals 32 and if you go
to 256 and 512 you get essentially the
same curve so the curve doesn't change
much over that so with T increasing
meaning weaker attack the attacker
search power is weaker that helps the
defender but it gets bounded again
essentially by this curve and even when
the attacker is in his words case he
does not too poorly and the sad news is
that the probability success is at least
ninety-five percent if you get three or
more search periods independent of lower
case T and the probably success is
approaching 1.0 even for small I
independent of T
ok so again boils down to the important
point is how many guesses does the
attacker get not how often you're
changing your key alright changing the
key helps a little bit so in case which
is a game where I think a random right
that's right in the face and you trying
to get a change right exactly and so you
mean this this this same analysis goes
back to des des key search machines and
and the people that did the work you
know the crypto work on this you know 20
30 years ago they'd say yeah that'll
make sense so so now we're mapping that
just to the password guessing problem
individual success is a sacrifice to day
the key I used yesterday you only
success right it doesn't seem to do any
good well this is all listen this is the
online attack so so he's got to use the
key he's got to find the key and then
he's got to use it and go online right
away so if if for example you're you're
targeting one individual this is
probably what they would what they would
do if if you're trying to harvest a
bunch of keys and then sell them online
in some underground system to someone
else then it's a different issue yeah
yeah okay all right so now let me make a
comment on the exhaustive search time T
being much much longer than the policy
period p policy change period so here
you would actually have the key changing
very very often before the full
exhaustive search and again the
important point is not the number of
changes or it's how many guesses the
attacker gets ok so the limiting case we
saw in that slide so now comment again
about offline attacks here so if you go
back into some of the original documents
i guess needs would be US government
documents probably the the ones which
most people would find before others the
original goal of password expiration
policies was stated as being to limit
the risk of password compromised in one
year to one in a million
okay so that was what they stated their
original goal was now this is entirely
unattainable today if we think about
offline attacks and for a minute we say
we assume there's no iterated hashing
lots of people still don't do it erated
hashing as a defense because modern
processing resources allow easily allow
seven to 10 billion guesses per second
and if you take for example an eight
character totally random password
password aren't really totally random
but let's just say they were and you had
a 93 symbol alphabet then you would be
able to search through that full space
of 52 bit space in nine days which would
mean to reduce the probability success
to one in a million you could be
changing your password every eight
hundred milliseconds yes yes well
actually and well yeah and so attackers
would typically have not just like
quad-core processors these are GPUs
you'd have a thousand of these or you
know where you rent them you know in the
cloud so you know this is this is one
processor which is very very cheap today
sure is not for processors per dollar
for all right yeah okay so so what this
tells us is that the the password
expiration period the the aging policies
give absolutely no protection against
offline attacks yeah well I generally
agree that these policies are useless
you're you're putting the context in
assuming the dumbest defender possible
who's not iterating at all not doing
anything and you know and in that case
right if you've got someone with if you
actually had 52 something that's a space
and 52 elements and you're doing things
sensibly you're in pretty good shape to
say this is never good and we're going
to start by assuming that you hash in
the dumbest way possible and then assume
that this argument carries over for all
other reasonable ways of hashing is that
logically doesn't follow
well the the argument I'm trying to make
here is what does the password
expiration policy grant you if if you
put in place a lot of these other things
which which are mentioning which are
very useful you know throttling and and
and you're going to put in hashing and
your courage you can you assault the
other stuff well if you do those things
you know you probably don't need to do
password expiration at all so that's the
that's the question yeah yeah well so so
so if we can if we can look and first
decide what does the expiration what
does the changing itself give you then
we can try try and weave together what
the best defense is it is like saying
well if everyone has to set their
password to dog either dog or cat then
and they have to go back and forth
between either dog or cat well clearly
clearly password reset doesn't help you
in this context therefore it helps you
in no contests that I don't buy that
argument well I mean like you know I'd
love to chat with you for the next
couple of days while I'm here about this
but what I want to do is I first want to
see you know I say right here you know
if we're looking at offline we're not
iterating what does it by okay so that's
what I want to establish all right okay
so here's a partial summary of what we
got we can look at first saying that the
exhaustive search period is about the
same as the password expiration period
or a little bit less then we can have a
multiple the password exhaustive search
period is a multiple of the expiration
period and then we can talk about going
through multiple searches over this
pasty items T and in all cases that
alone without these other defenses is
not going to help you an awful lot okay
so but this is just for equal probable
random keys this is not for user
passwords so can we use these bounds
these
asians that we have and say okay well
what happens when we actually have user
chosen passwords do things get better or
worse so the answer is the answer is
they don't get better and we shouldn't
be surprised by that so so this
background to empirical studies here
that help us understand what where we go
in practice with user chosen passwords
so the first ones is Joe Bono's study he
had access to 70 million yahoo passwords
here and a couple of the things data
points from his study for online
guessing if you were to try the most
popular passwords on each of a large
number of accounts so say you got ten
guesses per account you could get about
one percent of the full space of
passwords with simply ten guesses per
account okay so that shows you there's a
lot of skew and real user chills and
passwords and if if you had the optimal
attacker and they were able to carry the
massive search there was no throttling
and a lot of other things weren't done
what you should do if you've got
1,000,000 guesses per account ten to the
six gases per account you'd get about
fifty percent of user passwords this is
this is surprising this shows really big
skew on the front end of these
distributions right there's also a study
at at CCS published at CCS by we're in
colleagues they looked at 32 million
passwords including most of that is the
rock you data set if they held the 32
million passwords they took a sub list
of 5 million and then they took the
50,000 most popular passwords from that
sub list of 5 million and then they took
that 50,000 and guessed it on the
remaining uh what I guess it would be
the remaining I think there was well but
but of the 32 million I think there was
only 13 or 15 million that were unique
so I think of that I think there is
maybe 12 million 50 million left take
out five million and of the remaining
lists sub lists of 1 million they were
able to get about twenty five percent
over twenty five percent on those other
sub lists so big skew again their soap
so what
what this means is that the results are
going to be worse for the defender when
you're guessing against user chosen
passwords rather than crypto keys
because what's the attack you're going
to do is not going to guess randomly
he's going to try and use some impure
empirical data and guess what are
approximated to be the more popular
passwords Christmas users choose
passwords differently some are really
smart would be careful and then there's
my grandmother who really doesn't
generate the majority of people have
grandmother's because they know the rest
the rest of us who were smart we're all
in the room here because we're we're
working at Microsoft and we're computer
security experts right right I don't
want to tell you my password was before
I got into computer science but um so
you're suggesting that password
expiration policy gives more benefits to
the smart faster choosers that to the
dumb password choosers uh I don't
remember saying that but let me think um
the expiration policies well well if we
go through the crypto model um it if if
the attacker gets to guess it's a vision
of our guesses he's going to get through
all the keys but in practice he's not
going to guess the totally random ones
because he won't get to those ones
mainly because most attackers you know
they'd rather guess through more
accounts of weaker users than they would
be to try and get the tougher passwords
so so I guess that's that's what I'm
talking here on the next side the two
main differences the two main difference
is when you're trying to analyze for
user chosen to hazards rather than
cryptic keys is one there's a length and
password variation so the the we don't
even know what the full set of passwords
is because you know most systems don't
truncated a chicken you can have 16 or
32 or you know you know maybe 64
character passwords or longer but we can
model that by saying the vast majority
of users don't choose passwords longer
than 16 characters or 12 characters sort
of and that that's not a bad
approximation but the skew in these
distributions is the hardest thing to
model so what real attackers do and this
is what's important
is it they're what we call early
quitters they're going to not guess
through full exhaustive spaces they're
going to guess the most probable keys
against larger number of accounts and
never guess the very infrequent case
because that's not unless they're doing
a targeted attack just done on a
particular user that's not the way they
get act they're going to get access to
the greatest number of accounts duration
works as I won't get into logs into a
site offering months banga have to
change a password bang out to hunt out a
piece of paper and of course inventor
possible on very very short notice it
certainly made me dumber than it would
be if they gave me a week to think of a
password another week to train them well
so more about that in the last one but
there is there is a side effect to the
policies to keep into account as well so
um what happens as a result of the sku
is that you know if we looked at what
the attackers success would be over
guessing full spaces the results from
the from the idealized model be the same
but in fact rather than over the full
exhaustive period if you look at how
early in the period the attacker gets
success the more skewed the distribution
is the earlier we expect within the
period that the attacker is successful
so this makes online attackers very
happy because the online attacker gets
immediate feedback when they've guessed
the right password okay so the attack
success rates from the idealized crypto
model will be just as we said over the
full period t but um it will be earlier
within the periods the offline attack
the full searches are basically going to
happen pretty quickly with today's
hardware for the online attack this skew
is going to be very helpful okay so so
let's come back then to say what what
does what does password expiration you
does it actually stop guessing attacks
and I think the answer is no if a
password is guessable any if it's within
reach then dude then the password is
guest of all if it's guessable is
guessable and the attacker is going to
guess and if he doesn't get this period
you're going to guess at next period
eventually it's
a good defensive mechanism if you're
really trying to rely on it it's like
playing heinze can I get or you know
it's this it's the peas and the shells
and i'm going to move i'm going to move
the shells around a couple of times and
if you guess it wrong the first time
you're going to guess it right the
second time you know i mean there's only
so many places i can move the show right
if the attack of actor is not a guessing
attack then expiration periods can
temporarily stop an ongoing access if i
have a password and i'm using that
password continually to access your
account and you change your password
that's going to change in the password
is going to help but it doesn't the
expiration period won't stop continue to
access if there's a back door that you
put in the first time that you got
access to the account which some people
will do it doesn't undo any damage that
happens on your original access to the
county you stole a bunch of files jing
the password doesn't unseal the files it
doesn't stop attack vectors which are
persistent or which can re-execute so
for example persistent client-side
malware or persistent man the middle
attacks or things like that of online
basic attacks well if it's a if it's an
offline guessing attack i guess the way
i'm thinking of that is first of all
that happened so fast that he's probably
got access what the little niche that
the little glitch that came in with the
offline attacks is that if it is an
offline attack and you change your
password and we get into this whole
thing I've okay so that assumed that the
attacker somehow got a hold of a leak
password file and then if there's an
online attack and you change your
password you have to assume that he gets
a hold of the the leak password file
again right this is one of the reasons
why fly of these policies but I could
imagine that if you have some bleep if
the password file gets leaked and people
have to change their passwords
relatively quickly you know by the time
the attacker cracks all these passwords
that's it's already too late right so
this gets back to the earlier point that
was made is is that if they're cracked
and the period between them being
cracked and them actually being if
you're going to call it cracked or
compromise but then actually being
exploited as a result
of that if there's a lag and you change
it in that lag period you're okay but
you know if it turns out that you can go
through the full exhaustive search in
nine days I wouldn't want to be relying
on this for my defensive protection that
you know we just happened to be a day
ahead of the attacker using it first I
usually visit the reason beulah policy
is the second one that list it it's
trying to put some bound on when the
password does get compromised how long
does the attacker have access and you
listen reasons why that's not that
valuable but presumably those reasons
are not enough to convince people who
make these policies so it does I think
it's hard to say it gives no protection
also I think we have to acknowledge that
it provides some advantage the question
is at what cost because what we we
haven't measured it all in this in any
of these equations is what is the cost
and the impact to the users in the users
time and the typical assumption is well
you know they're unhappy but that's free
right because you know how you guys feel
about this well you know and in in
enterprise environments you know you
guys are paid well you should be made to
suffer a little bit for all that pay you
get and so you do some things that we
tell you to do and that's fine that
doesn't work as well in the online
environment of course we don't see
password expiration periods all on the
web very few very few sure the harm that
you're preventing what you have to
quantify the harm that you're preventing
through this policy and argue that it's
less than the time money that we're
spending on teasers and poor yet to
argue the there's some other mechanism
that would be or that because you have
these changing policies actually hurting
square no more
yeah so but I mean it is interesting to
think about the question though if if
the main advantage is that you're
limiting the period of access now and I
guess there's two cases one is that
you're hoping that that limit actually
the change happens before the exploit
actually well you know you're you're
hoping if if it's it you're stopping the
continual access well then you know
clever attacker you know you may well
already have what he wants or maybe he's
got another back door in so it would
seem that you've failed and and you're
trying to salvage something but it
doesn't seem like the policy that you
really you would really like to have a
defense that works instead that stops
access originally so okay so I'm pretty
much done here that so in the end what
what do the age the policies provide I
think it can temporarily stop ongoing
access now of course if you temporarily
stop it then you have to worry about the
next time that its guests did you stop
it in time that time too and then the
next time I guess did you stop so you
know cumulatively again this is not a
winning game a winning game but it I
think is useful to revoke some sort of a
delegated accessed you know you're on
vacation and you give the password to
your colleague or your secretary or
someone and the second but that's a very
useful feature now the second thing is
you know you know you guys are on shared
projects while you're an interim here
and and you come back and if there's not
a password change policy you come back
two years from now and you still have
access to all the accounts you had two
years ago when you're here so this
limits that but if these are the two
most useful if these are the two most
useful benefits is there is there a
cheaper way is there a cheaper way of of
addressing those issues then getting a
hundred percent of the population to
change their password every every 90
days the other thing it does as I
mentioned is it does force an offline
attacker into having to grab a new copy
of the hash file but if grabbing a copy
the hash file is is easy to begin with
and that that's probably a problem so we
can talk about
you know why that was possible to begin
with and why there weren't other
mechanisms in place to stop that from
happening the question of the summing up
question if you have one more slide two
ways dude listen this is there this is
my last one so um so there um so there's
you know from what I've shown here I
think it's fair to say there is limited
value not no value but limited value but
this is ignoring the usability impact
usability cost and perhaps one of the
most damaging factors here is is this
result from engines Aang and his
colleagues at North Carolina in there
CCS 2010 paper so if you know the
current password which is the case that
you're trying to to disrupt an ongoing
access if you know the current password
then it turns out because people have
these little algorithms that they use
because they have to updated every month
or three months it's actually for many
accounts or a significant percentage of
accounts it's actually possible to guess
the next password so they were able to
find they could guess guess for
seventeen percent of accounts user
accounts with less than five gases if
they knew the current password they
could guess an X pounds now that's
pretty devastating especially if you're
thinking well we're going to change the
password before it gets before it gets
used but if you actually know that it's
the current password and then you and
you were able to verify this offline and
then you try to go online it doesn't
work well you know the you know the old
one now you have to guess from that old
one of the next what's the next one so
that's a pretty pretty severe attack
against this password expiration policy
as well so I guess my view of this is
that the benefits are at best partial
and minor they're not zero but their
partial minor and there's well again
there's there's no concrete evidence how
useful there I'm trying to come up with
a bound on them not being useful but we
haven't seen any any evidence showing
how useful they are and so I'd like to
see some of that evidence from so
before they continue to use these and
then I'll leave it with you know what
alternatives could delivers deliver
equivalent or almost equivalent benefits
at lower costs to users so that's um
that's a lie I had enough happy to take
questions and discuss other cases it's
the most damaging thing about password
expiration policies okay which is that
every restriction you put on a user
causes them to choose from a smaller set
of possible merger and when you have to
choose a password that's going to be
easier easy for you to modify in 70 days
or 90 days you have to choose from the
set that you know how to easily modify
to make it memorable so you can make the
minimal change to it again you're going
to further reduce the you're going to
make it even easier to guess passwords
and you're going to create popular
passwords that weren't popular before
that are far more popular than some of
the way up to right I I understand that
and I think I think there's validity of
that but I've heard a counter-argument
to that as well and I've heard this from
Cormac and others as well but there's a
possibility we haven't seen the studies
but there's the possibility that by
forcing users to change passwords the
base password that they have in their
little mnemonic or algorithm or whatever
the base password together with the
little variation that they have whether
it's sticking the month on the end or
the some number on the end that rotates
from one to talk that might be harder to
guess then the password they would have
if there wasn't that's right so I'd love
to see a study that you were colleagues
dude but I we don't know we don't know
which of those plays out I agree with
that that point to some extent i've
always thought we make it to a point
where our IT department sends out a note
saying after careful study we decided
the very best s where it is full and
everybody should just start using that
because that excess my small of our
constraints but seriously I don't agree
with the premise music and if it's
because I don't change my password
because I fear there's some long-term on
going slow exhaustive search attack that
somebody is mounting against my password
and if I don't change it eventually
it'll go right I change it because of
leakage and leakage is not represented
in this model are you worried about
leakage like an animal or a password
hash pop I'm worried about seeing
explosives you tainment yeah exactly I'm
not a big fan of crypto key rolling
because I don't feel a leakage there so
much but here when I see all the time or
things like somebody's in a meeting and
they're logging in almost slaying they
think they're typing their username
although they think they're in the
username field or something you think
they're in the password field there are
children the user feels so it's
displaying and they get halfway through
and they realize it may suddenly erase
and if they are supposed to change the
password every 90 days they might walk
out of the meeting say oh I get so
change it now but if this is a password
they've had for five years the chose
very carefully and think is really good
they're probably going to go away say
well I hope nobody really saw that
because I don't really want to change
this password that I've had for five
years but but but to pick up on the
point that you're saying that that this
analysis mrs. is the basically the
observation attack that that the longer
you using a period the grip ass word for
the the greater and accumulation of the
probability that someone has seen you
use that password be this meeting I you
think they saw the first half and then
because it's something else six months
later somebody saw the second half I
think that's valid of course of course
the the grand you know the whole space
of all the tackers if that collapses
down to just the this tiny percentage
that is seen you physically enter your
password that's that's that's that's
smaller subset then you know attackers
from the others
sure but there are the weakest shell
okay fair enough like people at MSR give
talks external ways sometimes if they're
giving so that sort of a talking up like
on the projector like yes and it's
recorded in its made a new video then
pretty much anybody that watches it
carries to edge well you know if you
posit and see that slowed up yeah if you
have a video on to someone typing the
keys that's that's a that's a bad
leakage it's exactly a place where this
a partial leakage yeah sometimes that
over time for six months maybe I cut the
camera was in the right place I think
this I think that's fair but again you
know this reminds me two of you know you
know this great fear that everyone has
about sticking a yellow sticky on your
on your machine and and well you know
your your risk there is is you know your
family members at home your spouse here
the cleaning ladies all the rest but
again that's that's that's worrisome but
it's a tiny fraction of all the
attackers that are attacking from you
know the other side of the world as well
it's a bit of the entire you know
population of China trying to do video
click on the passwords and there
wouldn't be enough people to get into
the passwords it does get us to an
interesting other discussion about
generic attacks versus targeted tax and
if we start to talk about targeted text
or someone wants to get a year laptop
you know I think we need a whole lot
better than passwords securing our
accounts if we're worried about targeted
text I just don't see them ever you know
that's a very difficult thing to defend
against I've got one one question on my
monitor here and the question the
question is how about the benefit that
aging policies prevent users from using
the same password for all their
properties or accounts and certainly if
you're rotating having an agent policy
which causes your tape passwords
probably causes that you know no one
really wants to you know have this
password when it has to get get rotated
rotate all your other passwords at the
same time so that is that is a side
benefit of course from a usability point
of view you you know you might actually
want to be sharing your password amongst
a bunch of
low value properties but anyone that
actually has an expiration policy in
place probably considers themselves not
a low value property so i think that is
that is a potential benefit above the of
the policies it gets into password reuse
and other things don't know so whether
the consort his peritreme positive will
have impact on the distribution of the
puzzle whether it makes more whether
people will have more unique password of
that growth of next door sing whatever
females will choose or spouse or hub I i
would i would guess we haven't seen the
studies on this i don't know through our
studies but my guess would be it does
flatten out it does flatten out the
passwords but if you're rotating between
fluffy and dog and and and marshmallow
you know if it's flattered but not flat
enough to withstand attack then we don't
know that it helps right and and i guess
the real issue is if if it is as
predictable as the sang at all study
says that if i know one of your
passwords that i can get the other ones
with with you know reasonable
probability that might be a more
interesting question than what how flat
the distribution is have a good picture
of what's a what's a distribution the
old password you don't say so it looks
like so they probably just accept escola
database well yeah i think a lot of the
online attackers would just go to a big
database and it's growing all the time
but you take all the you take the
passwords at the head of the
distribution so you know that won't map
exactly on to you know the Microsoft or
Microsoft Research sort of passwords but
there's probably some overlap and you're
not it's not the join against a hundred
percent of the passwords you'd be happy
if you could guess maybe one or two or
five percent because that might get you
in to allow you to do some privilege
escalation attack or something else so I
don't really have an answer to your
first question though
a lot of good math and theory is it
possible to conduct an empirical study
on this to find out if it's harder to
break into you got to equal companies
once got a passive expiration policy and
what doesn't just is that something that
is possible let me let me ask mr.
schector and mr. Hurley here your
Microsoft colleagues weather will be
possible to care an experiment like that
I don't know which day would be helpful
I think black hats probably do it all
the time right but there they don't
publish so much and white hat says it's
getting a pass your legal team might be
a little challenging but but the short
answer is I mean I guess I don't think
that there are good data sets I think we
even have a good data set off it hasn't
been a large-scale breach of a data set
that had a password expiration policy
and government so we don't know what the
distribution how my guess would also be
that it's somewhat flattered but I we
don't that's kind of speculation we
don't know by how much we certainly
don't have any data that that ones who
do exploration it fare better than what
you cannot yeah it's really only been in
the last five years or so that we've had
some some of these large breaches that
have and some of the studies for example
but no study with the 70 million yahoo
passwords that he was able to they
cooperated with letting him analyzed in
a privacy-preserving way but it's only
in the last five years that we've had
the benefit of some large database data
sets like this this is one of the
challenges in research in this area's
you want to do empirically you want to
do ecologically valid research with real
datasets rather than made-up ones you
can I mean that's the ideal case and
it's hard to get exactly those passwords
there's been some studies that that show
that you know studies with a mechanical
turk and others have certain properties
that are quite quite useful for for
studying but it's it's it's a hard area
to get real data on and large very large
data sets is what you want a as an
example a eight character data sets all
right
793 carats there was an excellent number
if people have real keyboard and human
uppercase is easy now that we all type
on little postage stamps shouldn't you
come keystrokes which means going from
lower case a to the number one to
uppercase B to laura kc is God knows how
many keystrokes yeah i think i think the
mobile phones you know i would like to
see a steady no I don't think I i know i
can't recall having seen one but i would
like to see a study of how passwords
chosen from mobile devices what their
key spaces are compared to passwords
chosen on desktop machines i don't think
that would be a happy a happy result
either any other questions